David Bowie was a man who reinvented himself
countless times throughout his roughly half-century
long career; one thing that remained constant
about Bowie’s appearance, though, were his
eyes.
For anyone who doesn’t have Bowie’s likeness
burned into their consciousness, the musician
famously had one brown eye and one blue eye.
Or at least, it looked like he did in pictures.
You see, in actuality both of Bowie’s eyes
were the exact same colour- light blue, something
the singer himself was quick to point out
in interviews.
So why did it often look like they were two
different colours?
Bowie suffered from a condition called anisocoria,
which basically means that his pupils were
unequally dilated.
An estimated 20% of people have some form
of anisocoria.
But in most cases, it’s largely harmless.
However, in Bowie’s case, the dilation was
extremely pronounced and resulted in limited
vision in his left eye.
Anisocoria can be caused by everything from
a condition known as Horner’s syndrome to
a particularly bad migraine, though most people
will simply be born with it.
In fact, statistically a lot of you reading
this will suffer from a minor form of anisocoria
that is barely noticeable without close examination.
Finally, it’s also possible to have anisocoria
as a result of injury or trauma, which is
what happened to Bowie.
In 1962, when Bowie was just 15 years old,
he got into a minor fistfight with a friend
called George Underwood who was a one-time
band-mate of Bowie eventually turned artist.
The fight was over a girl that both boys had
a crush on.
When Bowie, who didn’t know Underwood also
had a crush on her, was bragging to Underwood
about “what a Casanova I was” with the
girl, Underwood, in his own words “was so
aggrieved I walked over to him, basically,
turned him around and went ‘whack’ without
even thinking.”
Unbeknownst to Underwood, this act damaged
the muscle in Bowie’s left eye responsible
for contracting his iris, leaving it permanently
dilated.
Now, people get punched in the face all the
time with no permanent damage, so why was
Bowie’s case different?
Well, as the singer himself would later state:
“It wasn’t a very hard punch but obviously
caught me at a rather odd angle” with Underwood’s
fingernail scratching the surface of Bowie’s
eye, damaging the aforementioned muscle within
it.
Despite efforts to save the sight in his left
eye by physicians, he was left with permanently
impaired vision- with Bowie describing it
as “very hazy”- and his pupil remained
fully dilated for the rest of his life.
Bowie would further explain in an interview
that the fact that his left pupil was constantly
dilated sometimes gave the impression that
it was a different colour to his right eye.
Pictures of the singer only played into this
idea since high-contrast photos, especially
those taken with flash or in a well-lit studio,
tended to emphasize the difference in the
size of his pupils (functional pupils being
wont to contract in bright light and all that).
This gave the illusion that his right eye
was dark brown, or even jet black depending
on the photo and lighting.
The left eye was also more prone to the red-eye
effect in cameras (see: What Causes Red-Eye
in Photos), further making pictures of his
eyes look markedly different.
The fact that Bowie’s eyes were naturally
a shade of very light blue also helped highlight
the difference, leading to rumors that he
suffered from heterochromia or even wore different
coloured contact lenses as a part of his carefully
tailored look.
Neither was true and Bowie was always quick
to point out that the way his eyes looked
was caused by childhood injury.
Since Bowie grew up to be a legendary rock
star where his ability to see wasn’t as
important as how cool he looked, he claimed
the injury actually ended up being mildly
beneficial to his career.
Some of the most famous images of Bowie highlighted
his condition and the singer himself was only
too happy to take photos that emphasized his
eyes, all of which fueled, as Bowie called
it, the “mystique” around his name and
image.
In fact, Bowie was so aware of how much of
a boon his condition had been to his career
that he reportedly ultimately thanked Underwood
for hitting him.
On top of quickly forgiving the man who cost
him much of the sight in one eye, the two
men remained lifelong friends, with Underwood
even providing artwork for some of Bowie’s
early albums.
In 2004, while performing in Oslo in Norway,
Bowie was hit in the left eye by a lollipop
thrown by a fan.
The candy missile was thrown with such force
that the stick became lodged in the singer’s
eye…
(Seriously) After having the lollipop removed
from his eye socket by a member of security,
Bowie told the gathered crowd “You’re
lucky you hit the bad one” before finishing
the concert.